taking an early Dive Into Summer parts
of the U.S and western Canada have
sweltered in unseasonal heat
with temperature records challenged or
toppled daily across the region many
welcomed the abnormal warmth
definitely appreciated super excited
because we get to be in our country and
run around in the water and splash and
pump so super excited but for others the
Heat's heightened fears are more extreme
weather events to come there's not much
I could do about it how I feel about it
it's you know it's kind of that's kind
of disturbing a little bit I'm a little
bit leery of the future for sure I see
there's already forest fires in Alberta
like crazy
so yeah fat Omen the extreme heat
gripping western parts of North America
has continued to fuel wildfires burning
in western Canada that smoke now
drifting into Eastern Canada and parts
of the U.S affecting air quality now it
is Extreme but not as exceptional as
what we saw two years ago where Canada
set a new all-time temperature record
high but still records were broken daily
and monthly records across the region
and to give you an idea of how high
temperatures are sitting well let's look
at Seattle we're nearly 15 degrees above
the average and that trend is set to
continue
so far this month more than a hundred
wildfires have swept areas in western
Canada forcing tens of thousands of
people from their homes and triggering a
state of emergency in Alberta Province
energy production in Canada's main oil
producing provinces also been affected
prime minister Justin Trudeau visited
troops trying to put out the flames and
with a hot and dry conditions set to
continue more troops are expected to
join in the coming days Cara Legg Al
Jazeera
tensions are rising in Pakistan as
thousands of supporters of the
opposition leader Imran Khan have been